Hello,
it's nice to see all of your phones.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome
Olivia Munn for x men apocalypse.
Thank you very much. Thank you for
the pronunciation. I tried very hard.
We practiced this. She said, uh,
it's a toxic Google. And I said,
why did you guys name it toxic Google.
We're Brittany fans.
Um, so huge, huge nerd movie.
You are an awesome Geek nerd icon.
How does it feel to kind of add this
to your, your wall of badges? I,
I still feel, um, and I felt at the
time, I still feel like, I feel like a,
like a nerd mole. I feel like, I think
they've let me in and I'm like, Hey guys,
I've got some stuff to tell you.
I'm like,
I get in there and I don't really
feel like, like, uh, you know,
I think somebody asked me
the other day about like, oh,
like to be part of this community.
Like how did that feel? Like a,
well actually I think in my opinion, you
know, that the nerd community or the,
especially the expert
community, it's, it's,
it's not the movies or the
biggest platform because
that's what Hollywood is the
biggest platform for entertainment.
But the community started long
before the movies and, uh,
and so to me it just felt like,
uh,
it felt like I was able to get in and it
kind of see what they're doing from the
inside. So I kind of don't,
I don't, I still feel like
the outsider on the inside.
What, what was your sort of first
introduction to the world of x nine?
Was it the comics was,
it was a comic books. Uh,
I grew up in Japan and I'm one of five
kids and we didn't have a lot of money,
so we, my mom would let us buy wine
and we'd all share it. And, uh,
but we got into all different kinds of
comic books. We just kind of read and,
but oexman was way back then I think.
Did you have a favorite storyline? Uh,
no I don't. I don't think
I, it was, um, no, I,
I never know all of them. Do you
have a favorite storyline from it's,
it feels like there's just so many, like
how, just so many, it's a great question,
but it's a hard answer.
I enjoyed house of m. Oh,
so you do have an answer. I'm
so, I didn't have an answer.
Easier question than I thought.
So I, uh, you know, you,
you are joining this one.
There's a,
we're getting introduced to a
ton of new characters. What,
what can you tell us about that luck or
your interpretation of her? So I like, um,
well this is the introduction
of, of Silak. Well, she
was introduced once before.
Um, but that was like a, like a
little blip of her. Uh, I, when I,
I was excited because I've always
loved Psylocke when I loved,
what I loved about, sorry, I like was
that she was, and I was reading it,
that she was a villain who
didn't have a problem killing.
You know, a lot of times people like
they have, they hesitate when they, when,
when they have to kill. Like, if they
have the only killed, they have to.
But I liked that silent.
She can create anything with their mind
so she could create a boulder and just
kill everybody and be done.
But I always thought that she
felt that was all too boring.
So she liked to kill up close and
personal. I always liked that. I'm like,
that's like kind of a cool quality light.
Not only that,
she's one of the Mutans who not only
has kind of metaphysical powers,
but she's physically a bad ass.
But yeah, like she's, you know,
telekinetic and she's telepathic,
but she's also really skilled
and she's a really powerful,
and that's what when I said to
us, so Simon Kinberg, he had,
he wanted me to do another role in,
um, in Deadpool. Uh, but it just, uh,
I don't, wasn't a real, I
connected with like, you know,
thank you for the opportunity, but I just,
you know, uh, I don't connect with us.
And it was a little serendipitous because
not that long after he called me about
Psylocke. And, uh, when I met
with him, I did say, you know,
I know you guys introduced to once
before, but like, you know, it's,
I like was the last one
added to this whole,
to the whole x went apocalypse movie.
They were,
they had the horseman already with,
with apocalypse and then they felt like
they needed a fourth and then, oh yeah.
And then there's Psylocke and
then they thought of me for it.
So when I met with them, I
said, you know, he said, it's,
we're introducing this
character so there's, you know,
it builds up into the movies
after and there's more stuff,
but this one is not going to be, you
know, a ton of stuff. And I said,
you mean dialogue wise or
presence wise? He said, no,
no, she just dialogue. Why six?
She's there, she's a presence in the whole
movie. And I said, well, like I like,
I'm not one of those people,
I'm not counting lines and I don't,
it's dialogue doesn't matter. I go, but
if you give her a bad ass fight scene,
then I'm in. And he's like, fine,
we, we, we got the fight scenes.
So like to me that was the monologue.
So for,
to me it only made sense to do Psylocke
if they were going to make her a really
strong and lethal and they give it,
you know,
all these guys get that ass fight
scenes and as the girl you got to like,
you know, it's always like really
slow and then you're doing something,
then you got to come up on him and
then he take, you know, I'm like, no,
can we just like grapple and fight and,
and really get into it.
And like I want to get knocked around
and I want to knock somebody else around,
like actually like do a bad ass fight
scene. And thankfully they, they,
they were all down for that. So what
was the training process like? Um,
I started doing, uh, I started working
with stunts, like learning wire and um,
and how to flip and stuff.
And then I started working
with a martial arts couple.
They have their own gym
and the husband can,
he is an expert in martial
arts and also sword.
So I started doing sword with him
and then I would do taekwondo.
And so my training and it being six,
seven hours a day,
pretty much every day for about four,
four months leading up into the
fight scene. And so by the end,
um, uh, I was, you know,
I did all of my fight scenes and all
of my stunts and that wasn't planned,
but in the end, uh, I was
able to just do it all.
I do have a taekwondo background,
so, uh, it's not like, you know,
I was like able to learn everything like,
so I, but I had that background already.
And then just training again with
them. Uh, it just, it was just,
it was just so much fun and because
it was everything for me to do,
if I was going to decide,
like I really wanted to do this fight
scene and so to get really strong and
powerful and to learn all these
things was very important to me.
And so then we took that time. Then by
the time the fight scene came around, um,
I was, you know, I felt, I mean, I
still feel like it's a weird thing.
You do martial arts. I do. You
do martial arts. Karate. Okay.
Um, do you know which, which kind of a
lot of, are you? Oh yeah. What is that?
The way of peace and harmony.
Really effective in a fight.
Just like someone comes at
you with a knife and you're
like, hey, chill out, chill,
dead. Um, uh, yeah. Taekwondo is,
it's like when you, when you do, do
people here, anybody do martial arts?
Oh my, my one security guy who's
been assigned to me. Thank you. Um,
you feel like really it's a different
feeling you feel capable of like there's
like, um, like a lot of
people get like, you know,
like they put on muscle and they know how
to like look lean or thin or booked up,
but there's a different kind of feeling.
It's like athletic strength
is what I feel like I have.
So I feel like really capable.
It's a good, it's a cool feeling.
I've heard it described as sort
of like a confidence, you know,
I think it's a little bit of
knowing that like, yeah, no,
that could maybe do something at a fight,
maybe. Yeah. If, yeah, I think not.
Maybe I like that's it is maybe
for me. Oh yeah. Well, no, no, no.
I'm saying probably not for your
peaceful fighting thing. I'm saying,
I'm going to say you have to call
me and I'll, I'll come. We should.
You should actually, have you ever
done your peaceful fighting technique?
It didn't work out very well, so
it's not, it's not the strong,
I mean it's a, it's a very nice choice.
Not the most protective choice. No,
not at all. Uh, but that's okay.
You seem like a very sweet person as you
mentioned before, you know, like is a,
I would say the whole x
meant universe is kind of a,
there's no good and evil necessarily.
Everyone just said who
has their own motivations,
but sidelocks maybe more willing to
engage in tactics that fall on evil.
But,
um,
how was it interacting with the other
kind of new folks coming in as a horseman?
And, um, the new cast of
characters. Yeah. It was really fun.
Uh, with, you know, everyone
is a, it's a, you know, we,
there were so many people in this movie
and we would all shoot different times,
but then at night we'd all
get together and we'd like,
basically like shut down a,
like a restaurant just for
us to hang out. I mean, not,
we wouldn't go in there and be like,
shut down because of us,
but with that we just take up so much
room that we have to like call ahead to a
restaurant and we all hung out. So it's
a really cool group of people. But yeah.
But I, it was speaking on the,
I'm the villain, the, you know,
good guys and been like, no
one's really like, you know,
most people want to do good.
Like, I think that's the, the, um,
do you guys know the backstory of
Psylocke? They people don't, you tell?
Well, well, okay, well,
back in third grade,
Psylocke was a she,
but she came from a good family and
she had twin brother and then she, uh,
and then when they were killed, you
know, she has these amazing powers.
And to me that when I was a kid,
that's what I love.
She is like what I thought were the
two most coveted powers, you know,
to be telekinetic and telepathic.
And so she was like,
Wolverine,
how he was used by people for them
to, you know, use his power is to,
to do their bidding.
That's what, you know,
Psylocke is alone and she's
always different. Leaders
have always, uh, you know,
taken her in and, um, manipulated
her so that, you know,
they could use her powers. And I think
she's always trying to find her, you know,
like, uh, you know, a
righteous leader to, to follow.
And she just happened to get in with
the bad guys. So she's really good.
She's really strong. She's
really smart. She's very loyal.
She's always had the wrong leaders.
And so if, you know the stories I like,
she wasn't, she's not, you know,
I'm bad in this movie, you know,
but the hope is that in the next one,
I mean, I probably will still be bad,
but there will be,
there's a switch because Psylocke and
the comic books she does, you know,
become good,
but she just needs the right person
to the right leader to guide her,
the right group, the right family. And
that actually in the complex happens when,
you know, the x men world brings her
in. Uh, but before that, it's hard.
I mean,
just in,
and that's what I think I always loved
about it as a kid was that, you know,
I grew up in a military family. We
moved around a lot and I'm half Chinese,
half white as are you. And, uh, and,
and being different, you know,
you're always in moving around a lot.
Always the new kid.
So I'm always the new kid and I
didn't look like everybody else.
That's what identified with the x
men universe. It's that it's the,
the people that don't always fit in with
everybody else that were ostracized and
that the people wanted to,
you know,
the majority of people want to like
put down or eradicate. So for me,
I identify with them because when,
when they, especially x and a lot,
that's all comic book world,
right? Where there's like the,
the guy who you know is different and
he's fighting against the rest of the
world, but an extra,
they all United together.
And because of that
unification, they, the,
their differences made them feel
special. And I felt like that's what, um,
you know, that's what I had in my
own family and that's, you know,
our differences made us closer and we
had this kind of United front against the
world. It's interesting in your book you
talk about sort of being a misfit and
identifying with nerds and nerd culture
and I think that's very much who the x
men are as well as the I as
you've said. Um, what, um,
now that you know,
you're at the forefront of that and it's,
it's cool to like these sort of things.
What's,
what's been your kind of
favorite revelation? Um,
now that geeks rule the
world and all that. Oh, uh,
what is my favorite revelation of
geeks ruling the world? Well, what's,
what's like the most fun thing for
you now that it's mainstream and it's,
it's cool like the x men and it's cool
to go to comicon and it's cool then I
think, um, I think that's, it's a
good, it's a really good question.
It's a cool feeling. And if it's a
good feeling, as a strong feeling,
it's a confident feeling where there's
people that want to judge people by way
they look,
um,
and or by the their interests or by
their ethnicity or their religion.
All of a sudden those
people like the bullies,
they're the people who look down on you
there. They're no longer the cool ones.
And in fact, anybody who
looks down on somebody for
who they are, their interests,
uh, the rest of the rest of the
world, they just know it's just not,
it's not cool and they know it's not cool.
Usually like when people,
like I felt like growing up, like
that's what, you know, it kind of,
you get ostracized and people are
always afraid to stand up to the bullies
because you don't want
to get picked on next.
But I think the tides
have changed and it's,
um,
and it's,
it's everybody is free to
embrace their individuality.
And I think that's the change.
Like when now it being a geek is cool.
I just think that means that being
an individual is cool and excellent.
I think we'll be great and I
love it and I'm super excited,
but I know it's going to be a fantastic
movie and I know how hard everybody
would, but he works to make it an amazing
movie for the fans and make it really
exciting and fun.
We are all very excited to see x men and
thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me guys.
Hey, high five. All right.